The president was interviewed by Fox News
host Chris Wallace in an interview that aired
yesterday, and it is unlike anything that
I've ever seen and I want to spend some time
today looking at it with you.
And it's really the stuff of history.
I mean, this is an interview that needs to
be analyzed, really, like that infamous Zapruder
film, because the English language is stretched
to its limit to even explain and describe
what took place during this interview.
Donald Trump at one point stopped the interview
to try to get documents proving Joe Biden
wants to abolish the police, which Joe Biden
doesn't want to do.
And Donald Trump was unable to prove with
those documents he tried to get.
Trump was sweating so badly that at one point
it looked like flop sweat.
He was glistening and dripping with sweat
throughout the interview.
Trump referred to World Wars one and two as
beautiful, beautiful.
Trump challenged Joe Biden to a cognitive
test and accused the interviewer, Chris Wallace,
of being unable to answer some of the test
questions on the cognitive test.
And that's like only the half of it.
Trump has insulted people in interviews, but
he was unhinged here.
Trump has said dumb and wrong things in interviews.
But Trump seemed impaired here.
So let's get right out into it.
Sit down.
Join me in this adventure, which is really
a horror show.
The country can never allow something like
this to happen again.
It is historic in its level of insanity.
I'm going to start with arguably one of the
most deranged moments of the entire thing,
which is that Chris Wallace shows Trump a
poll about Trump versus Biden on mental soundness,
which we'll talk about later.
More people in the poll.
It's a Fox News poll.
More people think Joe Biden is mentally sound
to be president than the number who think
Trump is mentally sound.
And Donald Trump starts saying not only can
he do better than Biden on a cognitive test.
It gets really ugly.
And he actually says to Chris Wallace, I would
do better than you.
You would struggle to answer some of the questions
on the cognitive test, completely and utterly
unhinged people.
Who is more competent?
Who's got whose mind does sounder?
Ivan beats you?
Well, I tell you what, let's take a test.
Let's take a test right now.
Let's go down.
Joe and I will take a test.
Let him take the same test that I took.
Incidentally, I took the test, too, when I
heard that you passed it.
Yeah.
How did you do?
Well, that's not the hardest task now, but
the last picture.
And it's the last.
And that's an L.A. nidaa again.
You see, that's all misrepresenting.
That's what it was on the Web.
So a misrepresentation because, yes, the first
two questions are easy.
But you couldn't even answer the last five
questions about you when they get very hard.
The last five.
Well, one of them was cut back from one hundred
by seven.
And let me tell you, not you couldn't answer
if you couldn't answer.
All right.
What's across many of the questions?
I get you the test.
I'd like to give it, but I guarantee you that
Joe Biden could not answer those questions.
OK.
And I answered all 35 questions correctly.
We're clearly desensitized by more than three
years of this because the president of the
United States told the interviewer that the
interviewer would be unable to do as well
on a cognitive test meant to screen out dementia.
Then the way Trump answered the questions,
and it's like just a blip, honestly, there
were equally crazy things in this interview.
Never mind other things that happened this
weekend.
There are some real questions here, though,
that that I should mention.
What test is Trump talking about?
Because Trump talks about the 35 questions,
the Montreal cognitive assessment, which is
as far as we know what from took.
And it was certainly what Chris Wallace was
referring to.
It doesn't have thirty five questions.
It's based out of 30 points.
But we don't actually know what tests Trump
is referring to.
Trump Nardy may not even remember the test
itself.
And as far as we knew, Trump took that test
a year or two ago.
But Trump recently said, I just took it.
When was that and where?
We're not aware of Trump being administered
that or any other cognitive test recently.
This was maybe the most mind numbingly bizarre
moment of the interview.
Then we get on to the Biden attacks here.
Trump says Biden wants to defund the police.
Joe Biden doesn't want to defund or abolish
the police.
And in fact, there's people on the left who
are mad at Joe Biden because he doesn't want
to defund or abolish the police.
And Chris Wallace calls Trump on it.
Trump stops the interview to try to get the
proof that that's what Biden wants to do.
Of course, it doesn't work that way because
Biden doesn't want to abolish the police.
Take a look.
You've seen deaths up in New York.
Deaths up in Chicago, shootings.
How do you explain it?
And what are you gonna do about.
I explain it very simply by saying it there.
Democrat run cities.
They're liberally run.
They're stupidly run.
Liberal Democrats have.
And running cities in this country for decades.
Poorly.
Well, why is it so bad right now?
They've run a poorly, it was always bad, but
now it's gotten totally out of control.
And it's really because they wanted to fund
the police and Biden wants to fund the public
labor.
He does not look, he signed a charter with
Bernie Sanders and he says nothing about the
funding.
No, really.
It says abolish.
It says a fund.
Let's go.
All right.
Me, you give me the charter plane.
So that led to a very interesting exchange
where he had a staff go out and get the highlights
from that 100 page compact that the Biden
team and the Trump team, rather, the Biden
team and the Sanders team had signed.
And he went through it and he found a lot
of things that he objected to that Biden has
agreed to.
But he couldn't find any indication because
there isn't any that Joe Biden has sought
to defund and abolish the police.
Just amazing.
I mean, lots of people wish Biden wanted to
defund the police or abolish the police.
But he doesn't want to.
And Chris Wallace, fact checking Trump in
real time there now.
In a moment, I'm going to get to Chris Wallace
more more deeply.
But for now, Wallace is at least doing the
basic fact checking now.
You'd think that after that bogus attack on
Biden completely backfired.
Trump wouldn't try another one, but he tries
to suggest Biden will end religion in the
United States if Joe Biden is president, according
to Trump.
Joe Biden will end religion.
Take a look and then we'll call.
Religion will be gone.
OK, life.
You could forget about that.
The whole question of life.
So be free.
When you say life, you mean abortion.
Absolutely.
100 percent.
That whole question, which is a very you know,
it's always been a 50/50 thing.
It's actually trending a little bit more toward
one side.
Religion is going to be gone.
What is that?
Look at what they're doing to the churches.
They won't let the churches even open if they
want to stand in a field six feet apart.
Now, I've said before, I don't care if a president
is religious.
I just want religion kept out of governance,
that secularism, secular secularism isn't.
People can't be religious.
It's in their roles as a public servant.
Religion should play no role in that governance.
But the fact happened to be Joe Biden's more
religious than Donald Trump.
It's not a preference.
I don't care about presidential religiosity.
But we know Trump is not religious and only
pretends to be religious in order to appeal
to evangelical voters.
Trump might even be an atheist.
I have a segment about this that I did a couple
of years ago.
Joe Biden is a religious guy and obviously
religion will not be gone under.
Joe Biden just bungled.
Bizarre claim after claim here by Donald Trump
at another point in the interview.
Trump refers to World War One and World War
two as beautiful wars.
Apropos of nothing, I mean, this was sort
of like related to Confederate statues and
monuments.
And he throws in that that the wars were beautiful.
And he also says, what are you going to name
stuff after all, Al Sharpton or something
canceled culture, the National Defense Authorization
Act, the.
Yeah.
You have threatened to veto it because in
the bill and this is supported by Republicans
as well as Democrats, it would rename Army
bases named for Confederate generals.
Now, this is a bill that funds military operations,
that gives soldiers a pay raise.
You're going to veto that as you'll get it.
Wish.
Hey, look, don't tell me this.
I got soldiers the biggest pay raises in the
history of our understood of our military.
I got soldiers, brand new equipment, brand
new jets, brand new rockets, brand name, 2.5
trillion.
I did more for the military than any president
that's ever had this kind of veto, because
I think that Fort Bragg, Fort Robert Lee,
all of these forts that have been named that
way for a long time, decades and decades,
the military says there is no excuse me what
the military says I do.
I'm supposed to make the decision.
Fort Bragg is a big deal.
We won two world wars.
Nobody even knows General Bragg.
We won two World Wars.
Go to that community where Fort Bragg is in
a great state.
This is the interview version of a sort of
a Rorschach test.
It's like an inkblot.
What do you see here?
It's complete free association.
And in terms of November, Chris Wallace gives
Donald Trump the results of a new Fox News
poll in which Biden is plus eight.
We're going to look at that poll in detail
later.
And Trump says, oh, it's all fake polling.
Mr. President, you'll be happy to know that
Fox News has a new poll out today, and you're
going to be the very first person to hear
about us in the national horse race.
Joe Biden leads you by eight points, 49 percent
to 41.
That's, I think, three, four points slimmer
than it was a month ago.
And on the issues, people trust Biden more
to handle the corona virus by southern 18
points on race relations by 21 points.
And even on the economy, they trust Biden
more.
By one point, I understand they still have
more than 100 days to this election.
But at this point, you're losing.
First of all, I'm not losing because those
are fake polls.
They were fake in 2016 and now they're even
more fake.
The polls were much worse in 2016.
They interviewed 22 percent Republican.
Well, how do you do?
Twenty two percent Republican.
You see what's going on?
I have other polls that put me leading and
we have polls where I'm leading.
I have a poll where we're leading in every
swing state.
Maybe I don't understand the Trump best mentality,
but it seems to me Trump could be prepared
to answer these questions about polls in a
more reasonable way, like if I were Trump.
And of course, I'm not Trump.
If I was dealing with being down by double
digits in most polls and I'm confronted about
it, I don't say the polls are fake.
I would say, listen, Chris, there's a reality
right now.
The country's in a tough place because of
Corona virus.
And as president, the buck stops with me.
This is me pretending to be Trump.
But but reasonable.
I understand the frustration.
I hear the frustration.
My promise to you and to the American people
is that between now and Election Day, I will
do everything in my power to singularly focus
on the virus because dealing with the virus
will help the economy.
It will help education.
It will help everything.
What matters is polling in November.
And I am going to leave no doubt in every
American's mind that between now and November
3rd, they will see that I am pouring my life
into resolving this situation.
And in the end, they will see that I've earned
a second term.
Like, wouldn't that be more powerful than
the polls are fake and I'm really winning.
You can't trust the fake news media on the
same topic.
Trump asked was asked whether he would accept
the results of the upcoming election.
Trump, of course, is losing in every poll,
but things can change between now and November.
And Trump is unwilling to say, I will accept
the results.
And he says mail in voting could actually
rig the election.
You don't know until you see it depends.
I think mail in voting is going to rig the
election.
I really do.
Are you suggesting that you might not accept
the results of the election?
I have to say, look, Hillary Clinton asked
me the same thing.
No, I asked you the same thing in the debate.
There is a tradition in this country.
In fact, one of the price of this country
is the peaceful transition of power.
And that no matter how hard fought a campaign
is that at the end of the campaign that the
loser concedes to the winner.
Not saying that you're necessarily going to
be the loser or the winner, but the loser
concedes to the winner and that the country
comes together in part for the good of the
country.
Are you saying you're not prepared now to
countries that I will tell you at the time,
I'll keep you in suspense.
Swell, Chris.
And you know what?
She's the one that never accepted regret.
She never accepted her loss.
She looks like.
Can you give it?
Can you give a direct answer?
You will accept the election to see.
Look, you have to see.
Oh, I'm not going to just say yes.
I'm not going to say no.
And I didn't last.
I made.
Remember that Trump doesn't realize that when
we talk about vote by mail this year, all
we're talking about is expanding absentee
ballots for anybody.
If they want an absentee ballot, they can
they can request one and get one.
But Trump seems to not understand that and
continues to refuse to say, I will accept
the election results.
Then we get into corona virus stuff.
Trump wrongly claims that we have one of the
lowest mortality rates in the world.
That's not true.
As I've shown you before, our deaths per capita
are the tenth highest in the world.
Chris Wallace calls Trump on it.
And the White House tried giving Chris a completely
bogus chart.
You're gonna have to take a look at this more
closely and we will talk about it after this.
When did the European Union?
Very early.
But when you talk about mortality rates, I
think it's the opposite.
I think we have one of the lowest mortality
rates in the world.
Well, we know we had 900 deaths on a single
day.
We will take this week.
Ready?
You can check it out.
He's got me the mortality rate.
Kaylee's right here.
I heard we had one of the lowest, maybe the
lowest mortality rate anywhere in the world.
You have the numbers was because I heard we
had the best mortality rate.
That's the first number.
Number one, low mortality.
I hope you show the scenario because it shows
what factors is.
OK.
I don't think I in fact, news.
I will put I want to put our stats.
You said we had the worst mortality rate in
the world.
Do we have to pass the sign?
Right.
It's a little complicated, but bear with us.
We went with numbers from Johns Hopkins University,
which charted the mortality rate for 20 countries
hit by the virus.
The U.S. ranks suffer better than the United
Kingdom, but worse than Brazil and Russia.
The White House went with this chart from
the European CDC, which shows Italy and Spain
doing worse.
But countries like Brazil and South Korea
are doing better.
So what's interesting about this is do you
believe Trump really is being told we have
the lowest mortality rate?
Like this is a very instructive clip because
our deaths per capita are the tenth highest
in the world.
What the White House gave Fox is a chart of
case fatality rates, which is death relative
testing, which is not informative here.
But what's extra wild about this is Trump
has admitted he wanted to slow down testing
to keep case numbers.
Blow the case fatality rate goes up.
If you keep case numbers low, so Trump's admitted
strategy of trying to slow testing actually
increases the case fatality rate, which isn't
even the right measure.
So this is like incompetence plus ignorance
plus self-inflicted damage.
And we're going to compare these metrics in
an upcoming segment because I want to make
sure that everybody sort of understands all
of the different components to this.
Now, in this next clip here is dripping sweaty.
Trump asked about mask wearing.
And he says, well, you know, masks cause problems,
too.
So definitely no national mask.
Mandate wore a mask for the first time in
public at Walter Reed this week.
Question.
The CDC says if everybody wore a mask for
four to six weeks, we could get this under
control.
Do you regret not wearing a mask in public
from the start?
And would you consider will you consider a
national mandate that people need to wear
masks?
No, I want people to have a certain freedom,
and I don't believe in that.
No.
And I don't agree with the statement that
if everybody wear a mask, everything disappears.
Hey, Dr. Fouche, you said don't wear a mask.
Our surgeon general.
Terrific guy.
Said don't wear a mask.
Everybody who's saying don't wear a mask.
All of a sudden everybody's got to wear a
mask.
And as you know, mask caused problems, too.
With that being said, I'm a believer in masks.
I think masks are good.
Bottom line is the president said he is not
going to issue a national mandate en masse.
He is going to leave it up to the individual
governors in their states.
Now, what's funny here is Trump lists only
reasons not to wear a mask, but says he still
supports them.
Like if he really believed, you know, Fouche
said don't wear one, even though that's been
explained.
Adams said, don't wear one.
The surgeon general, even though that's been
explained and masks, cause problems.
But I'm still in favor of them.
That's weird in its own way.
Like, why would you be in favor of something
about which you can only name negatives and
end and tie endorsements?
It doesn't really make sense.
And then we get to sort of this this kind
of bombshell, except it's sort of hard to
even believe Chris Wallace brings up.
Since Corona virus hit, some people have lost
health insurance.
People have lost jobs and their health insurance
is tied to the job.
So they've lost health insurance.
And he mentions.
Fortunately, we have the Affordable Care Act,
Obamacare, and people are signing up for it.
But you want to get rid of it.
Why are you doing this now?
And Trump claims that in two weeks there will
be a completely brand new health care system
to replace Obamacare.
What?
Yes.
Take a listen.
In history.
I want to talk you about Obamacare.
Since the pandemic hit, millions of people
have lost their jobs and thereby lost their
health insurance.
And almost half a million have signed up for
Obamacare.
Your administration just announced that you're
signing on to a lawsuit to overturn Obamacare
and replace it.
Why does it make sense to overturn Obamacare
with which people now are relying on?
Democrats are going to say the man who's wanted
to kill Obamacare is going to take away the
protection for preexisting condition.
First of all, we got rid of the individual
mandate.
Preexisting conditions will always be taken
care of by me and Republicans 100 percent.
But you've been in office three and a half
years.
You don't have to.
Well, I haven't had.
Excuse me.
You heard me yesterday were signing a health
care plan within two weeks.
A full and complete health care plan that
the Supreme Court decision on DACA gave me
the right to do so within herself.
We've got to sign an immigration plan.
Now, this interview was filmed a few days
ago, so it's not two weeks from yesterday,
according to when Trump said this.
He says we are 10 days from a completely new
health care plan.
What's the plan?
We don't know.
Some Republicans must know about it.
Right?
Somebody must know about.
If we're 10 days from a replacement to Obamacare,
somebody must know about it.
We've heard nothing about that at all from
anybody that's been asked.
And then here in closing, Trump attacks Fox
News on Fox News.
This was the start of the interview, in fact,
which has sort of become a constant side story.
Trump going after Fox News.
But Chris Wallace basically asks if Trump
understands journalism.
Some people were surprised when you agreed
to this interview to sit down with me.
What are you going to ask, especially because
of some of the main tweets that you've said
about me, Mike Wallace, want to be nasty and
obnoxious?
I will tell you after that one, my son Peter,
who knew Matt called and he said, nasty?
No, obnoxious, maybe.
But here's the question.
One of your beef seems to be that I put Democrats
on the show and I ask him questions.
And I guess the question I have is, don't
you understand?
It's my job to put Democrats on as well as
Republicans and to ask them probing questions,
just like I asked Republicans.
I'm not a big fan of FOX.
I'll be honest with you.
They've changed a lot since Roger Ailes.
And I watch people like Swalwell who I don't
even know.
He goes on to show he got less than one percent.
So Trump just doesn't get how journalism works.
And in fact, there is very little journalism
even happening on Fox.
But the little of it that is happening, Trump
hates.
So, I mean, what do we make of this?
This really is like nothing that we've ever
seen.
And my takeaway is anyone supporting this
is no friend of ours.
It just can't be like this has to stop.
Even if you like low taxes or something and
you consider yourself like a Mitt Romney fiscal
conservative, you can't support this.
You really can't.
And this is we have to be getting to the end.
One quick note about Chris Wallace.
Chris Wallace has been praised as wow, FOX
News host, subliterate host, obliterates Trump
and what a great job he did.
Chris Wallace is no great hero.
OK.
Chris Wallace is playing softball when everyone
else is playing tee ball.
So it looks like he's playing hard.
Hardball, right?
In other countries, a president this incompetent
wouldn't be able to do a single interview
because they would all go far worse than it
would be impossible for presidents in other
countries based on how media will actually
question presidents.
Remember, Trump said during this interview,
Hillary didn't accept the election results
in 2016.
What are you talking about?
Immediately conceded, and we barely heard
from her for a year or longer.
Trump said Biden would turn us into Venezuela.
And Chris Wallace said nothing.
Now, I understand you can't.
I've experienced this.
You can't turn every misstatement into a fight.
But the idea that this is some hardball interview
from Chris Wallace, this is like a five out
of 10.
And it looks intense because just about every
other interview is a one out of 10 or two
out of 10 when Trump goes on Fox and Friends,
when Trump goes on Hannity, et cetera.
So let's not give Chris Wallace more Plitt
praise than he deserves.
Although let's be clear that in in the Fox
universe, this isn't too common.
But remember, this plays into Fox's strategy
of saying we have a diversity of views on
our program.
We have Chris Wallace, who asks obvious journalistic
questions, and then we have everything else
who, you know, people just gushing about Donald
Trump.
Don't fall for the gushing praise of Chris
Wallace.
Let me know your reaction to this.
I'm on Twitter at Dipak The David Pakman Show
David Pakman dot com.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.